les bombardiers d'eau canadair sont
littéralement les avions pompiers les
plus célèbres du monde en 1963 apparaît
le cl 215 surnommé le bouillon pompiers
et quarante six ans plus tard en 2009
bombardier commence la production du cl
415 et voilà que l'avionneur canadien
diab et l'inde lors son nouvel appareil
le dhc 515 il peut déverser plus de 6000
litres d'eau en 12 secondes six pays
européens dont la france la grèce et
l'italie ont déjà officialisé leur
commande voilà la production
bars au début
philippe est la première
et il faut dire que son arrivée sur le
marché tombe à point jamais dans son
histoire l'europe n'a connu autant de
feux de forêt le président français
emmanuel macron on a même fait la
publicité il veut acheter plus d'avions
de type canadair on a 12 canadair
aujourd'hui en permanence y en a 10 ans
qui sont utilisés c'est inédit est ce
qu'il faut en en avoir davantage la
question réponse et de manière un peu
près sur wii
malgré tout la pression est forte pour
libre et les appareils atteint de
problèmes chez vraiment déchéance on a
besoin de 500 personnes ne tournait la
production à calgary pour construire
l'appareil et on a à peine une jeune
quinzaine de personnes à l'aise quand
même sont capables de travailler même si
le dh 6 515 sera principalement
assemblée à calgary en alberta sa
construction devrait bénéficier à un
ensemble de fournisseurs et créer des
emplois à travers le pays selon aéro
montréal reçoit sont des avions qui sont
motorisés avec des moteurs de pratt &
whitney canada fabrique dialoguer les
moteurs d'avions représentant à terme de
valeur sur un avion aux 25% ce prix dans
tous les cas les bombardiers d'eau de 10
haviland semble répondre à une demande
de plus en plus forte par leur
efficacité dans la lutte contre les
incendies et si gabriel pro 13 au canada
montréal